♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
MOMENTS AGO, BRETT KAVANAUGH
WAS FORMALLY SWORN IN AS THE
SUPREME COURT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
IT HAPPENED IN WASHINGTON.
IT HAPPENED AS YOU KNOW AFTER
A FULL MONTH OF VERY BITTER
DEBATE.
HERE WAS THE PRESIDENT AT THE
WHITE HOUSE CEREMONY MINUTES
AGO.
>> President Trump: ON
BEHALF OF OUR NATION, I WANT
TO APOLOGIZE TO BRETT AND THE
ENTIRE KAVANAUGH FAMILY FOR
THE TERRIBLE PAIN AND
SUFFERING YOU HAVE BEEN FORCED
TO ENDURE.
THOSE WHO STEP FORWARD TO
SERVE OUR COUNTRY DESERVE A
FAIR AND DIGNIFIED EVALUATION.
NOT A CAMPAIGN OF POLITICAL
AND PERSONAL DESTRUCTION BASED
ON LIES AND DECEPTIONS.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE KAVANAUGH
FAMILY VIOLATES EVERY NOTION
OF FAIRNESS, DECENCY AND DUE
PROCESS.
OUR COUNTRY, A MAN OR A WOMAN,
MUST ALWAYS BE PRESUMED
INNOCENT UNLESS AND UNTIL
PROVEN GUILTY.
AND WITH THAT, I MUST STATE
THAT YOU, SIR, UNDER HISTORIC
SCRUTINY WERE PROVEN INNOCENT.
THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: REMARKABLE
MOMENT.
YOU WOULDN'T THINK OUR LEADERS
WOULD NEED TO PUBLICLY DEFEND
THE PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE
AND IT WOULD BE CONTROVERSIAL
WHEN THEY DO BUT THAT IS WHERE
WE ARE.
POLITICALLY, OF COURSE, THIS
WHOLE THING TURNED OUT TO BE
UNEXPECTED DEBACLE FROM THE
DEMOCRATS.
THE LESSONS OF THE DEFEAT ARE
PRETTY CLEAR.
CREEPY PORN LAWYERS MAKE BAD
NATIONAL SPOKESMEN.
SCREAMING MOB OF CHILD
ACTIVISTS SCARE NORMAL PEOPLE
WATCHING AT HOME.
WILD ALLEGATIONS OF GANG RAPE
TEND TO BE COUNTER PRODUCTIVE.
IN OTHER WORDS IT IS IN FACT
POSSIBLE TO GO TOO FAR.
AND THEY DID.
IT'S NOT A COMPLICATED
MESSAGE.
YET, NONE OF IT SEEMS OBVIOUS
TONIGHT TO DEMOCRATS.
THE ACTIVIST LEFT HAS LEARNED
AN ENTIRELY DIFFERENT SET OF
LESSONS FROM THE KAVANAUGH
EXPERIENCE.
THE SUPREME COURT IS A SHAM.
THE CONSTITUTION IS
MEANINGLESS.
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE MUST GO.
ONLY A COUNTRY DIVIDED INTO
WARRING TRIBES CAN BE RULED
EFFECTIVELY.
IF WE CAN'T CONTROL IT, LET'S
BURN IT DOWN.
THAT IS THE MESSAGE THEY HAVE
INTERNALIZED.
WATCH HOW ACTIVISTS GATHERED
AT THE SUPREME COURT AND
REACTED AFTER THE KAVANAUGH
VOTE ON SATURDAY AFTERNOON.
KEEP IN MIND AS YOU WATCH
THIS, THIS IS NOT A CLIP FROM
A ZOMBIE MOVIE.
IT'S WASHINGTON, D.C., 2018.
[CHANTING]
>> Tucker: CHILDREN OF
AFFLUENCE RAGING.
THE RAGING CONTINUED ON CABLE
NEWS AND ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
WE HAVE TO ELIMINATE THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE THEY CHIRPED
IN UNISON.
"WHITE MEN ARE BAD."
THE MESSAGE WAS COORDINATED.
THE MEDIA FIGURES SEEM TO SAY
THE SAME THING AT THE SAME
TIME.
INDEED THEY WERE.
THEY WERE REPEATING TALKING
POINTS FROM THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, WHOSE INTERESTS THEY
FAITHFULLY SERVE.
FOR GENERATIONS CONSERVATIVES
CALLED THIS "THE LIBERAL
MEDIA."
BUT THAT IS NOT QUITE RIGHT.
THESE ARE NOT LIBERALS.
THEY ARE NOT PEOPLE WHO
BELIEVE IN FREE SPEECH OR
TRANSPARENCY OR DUE PROCESS OR
CHALLENGING CORPORATE POWER OR
ANY OTHER RECOGNIZABLE LIBERAL
VALUE.
THESE ARE PARTY PEOPLE.
THEY ARE HACKS.
AND JOINERS AND DRONES.
THEY READ THE LATEST
PRONOUNCEMENT FROM THE CENTRAL
COMMITTEE LIKE SCRIPTURE.
THEY REPEAT WHATEVER THEY ARE
TOLD.
THEY ARE ROBOTS.
LIBERALS USED TO DEFEND THE
RIGHTS OF THE MINORITY.
GOOD FOR THEM.
WATCH NOW AS HILLARY CLINTON
EXPLAINS HOW ENTIRE STATES
SHOULD LOSE THE POLITICAL
POWER BECAUSE VOTERS DON'T
AGREE WITH THE MAJORITY OF THE
RICH KIDS IN BROOKLYN.
WATCH THIS.
>> DO YOU THINK THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE SHOULD BE ABOLISHED?
>> I SAID THAT IN 2000 AFTER
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE 2000
ELECTION WITH AL GORE.
ANACHRONISM DESIGNED FOR
ANOTHER TIME NO LONGER WORKS.
WE HAVE MOVED TOWARD ONE
PERSON, ONE VOTE.
I THINK IT NEEDS TO BE
ELIMINATED.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE US MOVE
BEYOND IT.
YES.
>> Tucker: IT ISN'T JUST THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE EITHER.
IN THE PAST FEW DAYS  MANY
HAVE BEEN SAYING THE SENATE
ITSELF SHOULD BE CHANGED.
WITH THE DIFFERENT STATES
HAVING A DIFFERENT NUMBER OF
SENATORS.
ALL OF A SUDDEN EVERYBODY ON
THE LEFT SEEMS TO BE SAYING
THINGS LIKE THIS.
INCLUDING SUPPOSEDLY UNBIASED
REPORTERS.
SHUT UP, -- SHUT UP, WYOMING.
NOBODY CARE WHAT IS YOU THINK.
THE LEFT HAS NEVER BEEN BIG ON
SELF-AWARENESS.
THIS IS ONE ESPECIALLY AMAZING
EXAMPLE OF THAT.
THIS IS AN ONION PIECE WAITING
TO BE WRITTEN.
FROM KEN STEREO, FINANCE
BILLIONAIRE, ONE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S BIGGEST
DONORS AND THEY LISTEN TO HIM
ONLY BECAUSE HE SENDS THEM
MONEY.
BUT THE LATEST CRUSADE IS
AGAINST -- WE WANT TO PREPARE
YOU FOR A BLAST OF HOT
IRONY -- RICH, ENTITLED WHITE
MEN.
WATCH THIS.
SAVOR IT.
>> A GROUP OF VERY RICH, VERY
ENTITLED WHITE MEN WANTED TO
TELL THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE OUR WAY.
AND IF YOU DON'T LIKE IT, THAT
IS TOO DARN BAD.
>> Tucker: YEAH, THAT IS
WHAT TOM STEREO IS AGAINST --
TOM STIRE ARE AGAINST.
LET US KNOW WHEN YOU STOP
SNICKERING.
THINK ABOUT WHAT HE IS SAYING.
HE IS SAYING BRETT KAVANAUGH
IS NOW ON THE SUPREME COURT
BECAUSE THE MAJORITY OF THE
SENATE VOTED FOR HIM AS THE
CONSTITUTION SUBSCRIBES BUT
WHAT IS ACTUALLY HAPPENING, HE
IS SAYING, THAT KAVANAUGH WAS
INSTALLED BY A RACIAL GROUP TO
DISEMPOWER EVERY OTHER RACIAL
GROUP IN AMERICA.
THIS IS TRIBAL WARFARE POSING
AS DEMOCRACY AND YOUR TRIBE IS
LOSING.
THAT IS WHAT HE IS TELLING
YOU.
AS A FACTUAL MATTER THIS IS
INSANE.
THE LUNACY THAT WOULD HAVE
GOTTEN YOU BOOTED OFF A CABLE
CHANNEL FIVE YEARS AGO.
IT'S ALSO A LIE AND IT'S
DANGEROUS.
IT'S EXACTLY THE KIND OF
THINGS THAT HUTU LEADERS IN
RWANDA SAID IN THE EARLY
'90s.
RESPONSIBLE PEOPLE DON'T TALK
LIKE THIS.
SUDDENLY IT'S EVERYWHERE ON
THE LEFT.
NOT JUST THE WACKOS POUNDING
ON THE DOOR OF SUPREME COURT.
THE LINE BETWEEN DANGEROUS AND
THE DEMOCRATS ARE BLURRING ON
THE LEFT.
WATCH THIS.
>> I WANT TO INTRODUCE TO YOU
ANOTHER CHAMPION, ANOTHER ONE
OF THE PEOPLE WHO WORKS FOR US
ON THE INSIDE.
GIVE IT UP TO THE SENATOR FROM
THE GREATEST STATE OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA, MY
STATE.
NEW YORK.
SENATOR KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Tucker: IMAGINE A KLAN
LEADER INTRODUCING A PUBLIC
SENATOR AT AN EVENT THIS WAY.
ONE OF OUR PEOPLE WHO WORKS
FOR US ON THE INSIDE.
THAT IS THE EQUIVALENT OF YOU
JUST SAW.
SARSOUR EMBRACING GILLIBRAND
GOT NO MEDIA COVERAGE.
IT'S NORMAL NOW.
THE PRESS JUST APPLAUD IT.
HOW FAR CAN THIS GO?
SPEND AN HOUR WATCHING OTHER
CHANNELS AND SEE WHAT YOU
THINK.
THIS IS A GUY WITH A HARVARD
LAW DEGREE AT MSNBC EXPLAINING
HOW TRUMP VOTERS ARE NAZIS.
WATCH.
>> TRUMP HAS DELIVERED FOR
THESE PEOPLE ON THE THINGS
THEY CARE ABOUT MOST.
HE DELIVERED RACISM FOR THE
PEOPLE.
HE HAS DELIVERED MY --
MISOGYNY FOR THE PEOPLE.
NOW HE DELIVERED THE SUPREME
COURT FOR THE PEOPLE.
WE'LL SEE IF THE REIGN THEY
NOW HAVE CONTROL OVER ALL
THREE BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT,
SEE IF IT LASTS FOR 30 DAYS OR
TWO YEARS OR THOUSAND-YEAR
REICH.
>> Tucker: ALL THE OTHER
PEOPLE NOD.
OH, YEAH, THAT IS RIGHT.
A THOUSAND-YEAR REICH.
KEEP IN MIND HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF AMERICAN MEN DIED
TO STOP THE THOUSAND-YEAR
REICH.
A LOT OF THEIR CHILDREN AND
THE GRANDCHILDREN GREW UP IN
THIS COUNTRY TO VOTE FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
ONLY TO BE CALLED NAZIS FOR
DOING IT.
NOT THAT MR. HARVARD LAW
SCHOOL KNOWS ANY OF THAT.
HE PROBABLY COULDN'T TELL YOU
THE YEAR THE SECOND WORLD WAR